[Music]
hallo YouTube chest loss in my friends
this is guns in here welcome to my 20th
episode of dirty chest tricks against
Sicilian as we all know that against the
sveshnikov sicilian over the years
people have tried different lines but
black always come up with the new idea
however the recent trending line g3
caught my attention and the good thing I
like about this line is not only it
contain lot of traps but if you check
the database white score are very high
compared to all the lines so in this
video I am going to show you so of the
nasty tricks and traps in this line and
oral plan of campaign from the white
perspective the opening arises after the
following model E 4 C 5 Knight to f3
Knight to c6 d 4c cactus d4 Knight
captures d4 Knight to f6 Knight to c3
and now black plays this pneumatic brake
in the center with ePHI ok
Knight to be fie looking at juicy d6
square so black will stop this with d6
and after that the main line continued
with Bishop to g5 pinning down the
knight black counter-attack the white
knight with a 6 and after Knight 2 a 3
and the move b phi as there is a threat
of b4 white should continue with first
Bishop captures AB 6 Queen to f6 is a
pretty bad move due to Knight to d5 so
blacks big idea is he wants to capture
with the G porn and when white diffused
the threat of b4 with Knight to d5 we
come to a critical junction where black
has tried mainly to up this move frankly
speaking it doesn't matter whether black
continued with Bishop to g7 or f5 all of
this line
our transpose to each other so for your
convenience I have considered the only
one model and that start with the most
popular f5 well here comes the starting
point of a trap aligned and that start
with this trending move 11 g3 and I must
say lot of black player gets surprised
and with my own experience what I found
out that most of them are not aware how
to handle this line black has two
options whether to capture on e4 or
continue with Bishop to g7 first let's
look at F captures evil which looks more
natural in this position and white
response is very obvious yep trying to
regain our pawn back now black should
play the move Bishop to g7 and avoid
hanging on to this extra pawn however
you will find out that especially in the
quick game black try to hang on to this
pawn and that's where our first trap
comes into the picture and this is
actually happen in one of my blitz game
where my 2,000 rated opponent continued
with fi supporting his extra pawn and
thinking that wow white has done
something horribly wrong well the matter
of fact is now black key is going to
checkmate it in just four moves yup you
heard it right so kindly pause the video
and find out the sequence where you can
check meet your opponent in style
did you find it let's see the first move
is very obvious Queen to h5 Shack King
to d7 Queen to a5 Jack King to e8 Queen
to h5 check again but the big point is
finally when the king arise on the d7
there is no F pawn and that's why Bishop
to h3 it's a deadly checkmate at the
16th move of the game isn't that
wonderful
the second move I want to consider is
Bishop to a5 another way to hang on to
this pawn but this time around White has
another trap EMU and that is f3 well
black should forget about this pawn and
continue with Bishop to g7 however many
greedy players will continue with pawn
takes f3 thinking that we are clear pawn
up but guess what after Queen captures
f3 attacking the bishop doesn't matter
wherever the bishop moves our next move
is very obvious Knight to f6 and black
can a disasterous position just within
the opening stage let me show you how
quickly black game can fall apart we are
following a game where 1800 weighted
black opponent continued with Mike to d4
counter attacking the White Queen but
what he missed is after this simple
sequence
Knight to have 6 Jack Queen takes up 6
Queen takes rook in the corner and after
King to e7 and the moon castle in the
Kings side not so surprising white
emerge with an exchange of at just 17
move of the game and don't forget this
poor helpless King which is stuck in the
center of the ball
so you can see that if black try to hang
on to this pawn then worst is waiting in
the wing so many wise black player just
forget about that pawn and continue with
the piece development such as Bishop to
g7 planning to castle on the Kings side
okay in that case we will get of a pawn
back and now here the main line is
Bishop to e6
but as this line is very new not many
black players are familiar with the
territory and what they come up is this
routine Castle moon thinking that now we
get very good King side attack but just
one move from the wide and black and see
the danger looming on his camp can you
see it well I was surprised when the
first time I see the moon Knight to b3
so the first thing first we are checking
the night black cannot defend with the
bishop so for example if he played the
move Bishop to b7 then white can unleash
Queen to g4 and Knight to f5 which is
very painful for the black camp and
again you can't play Bishop to d7
because the d6 pawn is hanging so more
or less black is forced to defend this
pawn with the Queen and as for the
database 70% of the games continue with
Queen to c7 which at first sight looks
very obvious however it straight away
fallen into another deadly trap of this
line to be honest it is not easy to see
at this point but as we move on you will
see the point white will continue first
with Queen to h5 threatening a checkmate
black has to stop it
so at 6 is the only logical reply
and after that can you guess wife's next
move
yup the obvious and aggressive g4 and
suddenly black position is completely
paralyzed none of these three pieces can
move black can't play f6 due to the move
Queen to g6 and the most problematic
thing is what is threatening the Muji
file which is unstoppable for the black
camp again I like to show you a model
game from the data base where a 2600
rated opponent literally kill the
Grandmaster in just mere 20 moves black
player at this position continue with
rook to a7 unpinning the knight and the
white response is very obvious GFI black
respond with a counter attacking move fi
but after he catches up six route
captures f6 it turned out that F Phi was
a big-time disaster and just two moves
Queen check looked to a fade and queen
capture c6 suddenly black found to his
horror that he is a piece down and there
is not a single compensation exist over
the board so you can see after F
captures e4 how much trouble black and
get if you continue with his routine
moves so many black players think that
okay forget about capturing the pawn
let's continue with Bishop to g7 and
after Bishop to g2 castle on the King
side well surprisingly enough even this
move is not accurate and here comes the
four amazing trap in this line starting
with E captures Fi
Bishop captures a fire at first sight
this position looks very innocent but as
happened in other line we have this
trademark move Knight to e3 and I can't
tell you how many mm plus rated opponent
has fallen into this trap
well White has attacking to piece and
accordingly Black has two choices but
both leads to the opening disaster
number one Bishop to d7 is a pretty bad
moon as the simple move Queen captures
d6 and white emerge with an extra pawn
with an ongoing pressure the other move
Knight to e7 again fails but you need to
know the sequence here I think Bishop
captures 8 is a wrong move instead of
that white shoot first capture this
Bishop and after Knight captures a fire
as the Black Knight is aiming for the d4
square we need to first kick it with
Quinn to d3 well now if Knight to d4
then c3 is a very strong reply so
accordingly many games continue with 927
but finally now it's the right time to
capture the rook as after Queen takes
and Castle black doesn't have any
counter tactics and once again we are
merging with exchange up advantage
that's it guys I hope you enjoy and
launders wonderful tricky g3 line
against the Suez Nicole as you have seen
in this video this line contain lot of
traps so if you study well then you can
literally apply in the tounament
practice and get some great victories
thank you for watching this video feel
free to like subscribe and comment and I
will meet you in my next episode very
soon bye and take care